hey guys Nick here with some Need for
Speed payback gameplay captured at e3
this PC showcase includes eight minutes
from payback single-player campaign and
four more explosive III content be sure
to hit that subscribe button Koenigsegg
Agera zero to 60 in 2.7 seconds and the
house is shiny new toy but be a pity if
something happened to it you read my
mind they're transporting it across city
limits in two hours we intercept then
grab the cargo it'll be part of a convoy
what are you thinking quick hit and run
get me close to the truck and I'll take
care of the rest all right time to show
the house we're back
let's go grab ourselves a hydra drones
online that are looking for the convoy
you guys better hurry to the run day
all right ty remember the house will
have enforcers protected
I have to get rid of them first get me
on the truck before it reaches the
Emperor Valley tunnel
aerial surveillance will be blind inside
perfect time for you have run
bulletproof plan worst-case scenario we
have provide right
that won't be necessary
how long have you known Jets she always
has a plan
oh and the plan Lee and plan D up and
plan E
you got that right
pull up here
I feel trust almost there
and they blow them up
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
get me close to that truck before it
hits the tunnel
house won't let us anywhere near the
truck
ah nice tie one down one to go
that's what I'm talking about let's get
that drunk
Mack anything else headed our way driven
quit
yes you ready get me in position
what's going on I got brake-checked hard
will
what the hell this guy's out of his mind
there's something much bigger going on
here they window this far for just a car
what's the play new plan forget the
tunnel we get him before it reaches the
city oh you guys
back up they go back up I see them
you
frickin kinda what they offer
they're going down either way
come on inside getting away not for long
drive my Falcons away we'll handle it
come on get rid of these guys
guys
I think we lost the muscle Mack yep
that's rock duo
no way you can make it on the back
what's the plan Jess I don't know yet
get me closer
yet I've got a really bad idea ladder on
the side get up on his right guys he was
so much policing coming it's now or
never just do it
good job chief let's take this baby home
let's see what she can do
guys don't come here
okay boys let's even the odds
hey Matt you built us all yourself an
artist can fend any scrap into a
supercar this crew right here as the
future
we own these streets Tyler's house
always wins
not tonight it didn't
you